Fabiano you surge through the rankings
in that final stretch how did you
approach this final play of Blitz well I
mean
before today I didn't really have any
Ambitions for anything in the first
place was out second place was out you
know I mean pretty much any
hope of like a really successful
tournament but
um
yeah I mean I'm almost a bit embarrassed
with how it happened at the end because
of course I should have lost that last
game
uh I did play one really good game that
I'm proud of against Jeffrey and at
least I think it was right that was my
feeling
um which is nice that's that's at least
one nice uh and yeah I got lucky at the
end which is which is also good
would you pinpoint that game as the
moment when you felt like you could be
playing for like third position and
actually that would be a final good
score
no I I was trying I mean I thought I
could fight for fourth I didn't think
that I would be able to share a third
but Ford seemed relatively doable at
some point very good and how would you
assess your performance so far and how
do you feel before the start of the
singfield cup well I'm pretty pretty
lousy play but uh the result was better
than my play and um and yeah I ended on
a high note so I have the positive
emotions from the good last day well
just a couple of days to get some rest
we'll see you at the singfield cup
congratulations I'll be a quick question
for you uh the singfield cup of course
is uh the home of one of your greatest
if not greatest results ever uh your
thoughts looking forward to the final
event of the grand Chester or how you
going to handle it well there's a lot on
the line I mean the tournament itself
all the best players in the world but
also the I I have still have some shot
at like a decent overall Grand chess
tour standing like maybe third is Within
Reach now
um because the results
went my way in this tournament I mean
overall
um
uh so yeah uh I mean today was very
important for my fight for for let's say
third or or maybe second or something
like that in the grand Chester if I have
a very good singfield cup especially
because you finished tied with Maxim was
also very close to the top yeah yeah
this is a great result for Maxime of
course it's um he he was basically not
connect with a bunch of players and now
he's separated somewhat from them
Fabiano congratulations we'll see you in
a couple of days thank you absolutely
our congratulations as well